now we move on to the derivative okay
the actual rate of change I can work out
what that entity is because it's not 1
because I had the function already right
so this differentiate now as I do this
by the way remember I mentioned that
sometimes you'll leave your equation in
terms of the K because the case just
kind of gross - right okay so I'm gonna
say T is equal to this where K is and
I'm going to find it it's kind of
redundant to put this in because I've
already established this like three or
four lines yeah but that's only because
I did this question right before so if
this question was out on its own you
want to say this line it's kind of
important so that later on when I say K
you know what it's a furniture okay yeah
differentiate what happens the constant
will simply vanish and then here just
general right so I've got minus 78 okay
Katie now you can see why DT DT right
it's not simply your temperature
function times the constant of
proportionality doesn't work right
because your temperature function has
other stuff flying around but namely
this 22 so there's my derivative in
terms of time so how do I test and turn
it so it easy in terms of temperature
okay now let me factorize which doesn't
look like it's gonna do anything before
I make it a little more obvious to show
you it's actually not that difficult
a lot done is take the - k-town right
but that leaves women is this 78
business how do you see that this is a
really important part about temperature
function right in fact it's almost the
whole temperature function all I'm
missing is 22 right so let's put me to
death
okay now pause that's the temperature
function okay in a second I'm gonna
substitute that whole thing for capital
tape because then it'll be a function of
Kathleen tape right but as I heard you
know right we can't just go around
really really adding things on server
added 22 I'll just subtract meet you I
can still substitute this part for
capital team so now I'm basically there
there is by function for how the
temperature is changing in terms of what
the temperature is okay does that make
sense now some of you undoubtedly won't
recognize this because that is this line
here is its law of cooling
maybe not Newton's law of cooling it
looks like this minus K t minus e where
T is the temperature of your object and
ease the temperature of your environment
okay 22 we don't use this for the same
reason we don't use the physics formulas
because it takes out all of the actual
bats that that is about okay it's on
Automator right however it's still
really helpful because can you see we
were so close right we're really really
close right this line up here decide the
fact that across that says how you're
changing your rate of change it's
proportional to your temperature okay
but it's not proportional to temperature
its report to the difference in
temperature you see that
okay not proportional to the temperature
itself but this is this difference
factor okay and what you have is this
kind of situation coming up all the time
when you've got something changing and
there's some external constraint on it
right like a something is cooling down
to an ambient temperature or for
instance something that's going to reach
a natural concentration or a population
that's limited by like food or disease
or all those kinds of things so this
difference bit gets at that constraint
right or a Miss done let's just finish
off this last bit just apply how long's
it gonna take to get to 30 degrees what
would you guess by the way it took five
minutes to get to 60 degrees
five minutes Santis you see is five
minutes to drop 40 degrees off the
temperature so what would you guess I
want you to write down a number we've
got this as our sort of fence post okay
just make an estimate maybe I'm certain
iodine GPA up so you're committed to it
okay in pens and then we're gonna do the
mass I will see how close you were okay
so your written down let's do it
go mad you I can't do it because I'm
cheating cuz I'll write a video answer
so let's give it a go
okay if I want to get to 30 degrees I
need to do is take my temperature
function right pop 30 the left-hand side
solve for tip so let's go
okay now again I'm trying to emphasize
like the reason why I don't actually say
what K is even though I know exactly
what K is is cuz it just makes this
thing take twice as long to write and it
doesn't change any of the numbers that
you're working with right so I get to
this last line and I'm about to hurl it
into the calculator so what do you get
can we get it to two decimal places I
don't got there yet
there's a value cake
any tickets fifteen point eight three
six eight three six eight three three so
I guess I'll call that okay
so almost 16 minutes who is clutch whose
clothes what you get definite 16 anyone
okay yeah excellent yeah if you ran to
the nearest hundred I'll be pretty close
to you okay anyway all right well done
no fifty okay about sixty minutes does
that feel about right it didn't take
long to drop 40 degrees right I only
want to drop another thirty which is
less right why does it take almost white
with more than twice as long to drop
that next thirty degrees because of what
the function looks like as you're
reducing in temperature you're losing
temperature slower and slower so it
takes you quite a long time to actually
get there